What kinds of jobs did you have since first arriving in the country?
We were gardeners and we were cleaning offices.
You remember that?
We had the night shift cleaning.
That's why you know we had to take you, you and your brother.
I didn't have a babysitter.
I have memories of running into everyone's office and eating candy from their candy dishes.
I remember being with my brother in our pajamas with the little plastic feet.
And I also remember you would always buy us a Cup-O-Noodle from the vending machine...
Right.
...like a snack and then put us to bed on people's office couches.
And then you'd carry us to the car when you guys were done cleaning the offices.
I remember that.
Did they ever know, did your bosses ever know that you took your kids?
No, I don't think so.
Is there anything that you've never told me but want to tell me now?
When we first came here, we went through a lot of things, like not eating.
I guess, for six months your father lost his job and we never told you that.
I do remember a lot of beans, bean tacos.
When you asked us, why the same thing?
Remember?
I didn't want to tell you why.
If you could do everything again, would you raise me differently?
I would dedicate more time, I guess.
You know, I was so busy going to school too that I guess I neglected you a little bit.
No.
For me, watching you go to school with two kids and trying to make ends meet,...
...that was the biggest inspiration for me to finish college.
I thought there's nothing that could stand in my way that didn't stand in yours, more.
It's the most important thing for me, having gone to college.
And I feel like anything I do from here on out is okay because I've already achieved my dream.
Everything else is icing on the cake.